[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
while our attention is fixed on the
assault on the capitol the coronavirus
is rampaging through the country for the
first time yesterday
u.s officials recorded more than 4 000
covid deaths in a day more than 11
700 people have now died in just the
past three days
and 583 people died in california
alone yesterday our lead national
correspondent david begno is in the
mission hills section
of los angeles david good morning
anthony good morning those numbers you
just mentioned can never become
normal you know last week we were being
told that here in l.a county someone was
dying with covet every 15 minutes
now we're being told it's once every
eight minutes look we're at providence
holy cross medical center
in north l.a county this morning because
they led us inside to see what was going
on
and we're going to start with one of the
patients our team had a chance to speak
with
this is ophelia conscious reynoso almost
every sentence is a struggle to get out
i thought i'm not going to get it she
said because i'm taking care of myself
still the 73 year old says she's
hospitalized with covet
and five other family members got sick
as well she had trouble just getting
these words out she said
it's so sad being alone here
is medical director of palliative care
here at holy cross
she says some patients seem to die in
part
from a broken heart it's so lonely the
only thing that they have is the tv
and us the mayor of los angeles eric
garcetti
says that three of the city's hospitals
are now in crisis mode
and others are moving closer to that
unthinkable step
of rationing care if you can spare a
doctor or a nurse if you can spare
anything please
send it here we're americans take
methodist hospital
a triage team has already been assembled
to decide who gets treatment
and who doesn't and while they're not
yet active the situation looks
increasingly dire
the hospital system is bent about as far
as it can bend
the next sound may be a snap california
is one of at least eight states where a
highly contagious variant of the virus
has been discovered
just under 6 million people nationwide
have gotten their first vaccinations
now remember the federal government
wanted 20 million vaccinations as of
last month
with the variant on the rise
vaccinations
must move faster warns dr ashisha this
variant will become
dominant will become the main source of
infection within about six to eight
weeks
we don't have time to lose and if we
fall behind and this variant
really takes off across the country it's
going to be much much harder to bring
this dynamic under control
for now ophelia is asking god
to give her some strength to go home
that's where my family is waiting for me
she says and i need to return
conscious reynoso told our team please
let everyone know wear a mask
not only to protect themselves but to
protect the workers here at the hospital
gail you got the sense she is so
grateful as she fights to get better
for the medical care she's receiving yes
david i don't speak spanish but i did
hear the word familia we know that and
at this moment what you need more than
anything is family it's heartbreaking
hear the nurse say all she has right now
most people is a tv
and us it's really tough a message again
please wear your mask david thank you
thank you very much